[موسيقى]
هو صون 17 هو صاروخ عابر للقارات يطلق من
منصه متحركه على اليه كبيره تم انتاجها
محليا هذا يعني ان كوريا الشماليه باتت
تستطيع تصنيع ما تريد من هذا الصاروخ
ونشره في ارجاء البلد هو صوم 17 هو صاروخ
مكون من مرحلتين وكذلك يستخدم الوقود
السائل مما يعني انه يجب تزويده بالوقود
قبل الاطلاق مباشره وليس قبل النقله مما
يزيد من فتره تحضيره للاستخدام
[موسيقى]
يعتقد المراقبون انه هو سونك 17 يستطيع
حمل عده رؤوس حربيه مما يصعب عمليه
اعتراضها ويزيد كذلك من قوتها التدميريه
يعتقد الخبراء ان اول تجربه لهذا الصاروخ
كانت في اكتوبر من عام 2020 والتي صادفت
الذكرى الخامسه والسبعين لتاسيس حزب
العمال الحاكم برئاسه كيم جونغ اون
[موسيقى]
خلال عام 2022 تم اجراء تجربتين لنفس
الصاروخ وصل في اخرها الى ارتفاع اقنع
المسؤولين في الولايات المتحده وكذلك في
اليابان بانه بالفعل صاروخ عابر للقارات
ويمكن ان يصل مداه حتى 15 الف كيلو متر
هذا الامر سيضع اي هدف في الولايات
المتحده في مرمى نيران فيانغ
[موسيقى]
مؤخرا اجرت كوريا الشماليه تجربه اخرى
لنفس الصاروخ وصل خلالها الى ارتفاع تجاوز
سته الاف كيلو متر وطار لمسافه تصل الى
الف كيلو متر لاكثر من 69 دقيقه قبل ان
يسقط في عرض البحر
[موسيقى]